[Musik]
okay es geht um eines der größten
probleme unserer zeit wir brauchen
energie immer mehr und immer
nachhaltiger gleichzeitig bedeutet das
aber auch dass wir energie immer länger
speichern müssen und hier sind die
optionen ziemlich begrenzt herkömmliche
akkus bieten uns mit einer speicherdauer
von ungefähr ein paar tagen nämlich
keine gute lösung und andere
speichermöglichkeiten haben wir kaum
oder wie ist also der stand der dinge
und was in unserer aktuellen
möglichkeiten genau das erfahrt ihr
jetzt
[Musik]
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
schreitet ja zum glück voran beim anteil
in der stromerzeugung sind wir mit den
erneuerbaren energien schon ungefähr bei
42 prozent das sind natürlich erstmal
richtig tolle neuigkeiten aber damit
gibt es ein großes problem
strom wird ganz viel erneuerbar erzeugt
ja aber die meiste energie wird durch
fossile energieträger geliefert die
allermeisten autos fahren zum beispiel
noch mit benzin und diesel also erdöl
und geheizt wird in deutschland immer
noch primär mit gas wenn wir die energie
hiervon mit einberechnen dann ist nur
16,1 prozent der verbrauchten energie
nachhaltig wir müssen also so genannte
sektoren wie zum beispiel verkehr oder
heizen erst einmal elektrifizieren wir
müssen aber nicht einfach nur mehr
erneuerbaren strom produzieren sondern
auch das speicherproblem im blick haben
eine große herausforderung wird es
nämlich den winter zu überbrücken nehmen
wir zum beispiel die stromerzeugung
durch solarenergie von märz bis
einschließlich september liegen wir über
dem jährlichen erzeugung ist
durchschnitt das heißt wir müssen uns
von diesem zeitraum elektrische energie
aufbewahren um sie dann von oktober bis
februar nutzen zu können wo wir
unterdurchschnittlich wenig strom
erzeugen dadurch hätte man eine jährlich
konstante versorgung obwohl man im
sommer sogar meist weniger strom
verbraucht als im winter wenn man dort
zum beispiel nicht so viel heißt aber
dadurch wird die speicherung für den
mieter ja sogar noch wichtiger alles
klar was ist denn dann mit akkus der
technologische fortschritt der letzten
jahrzehnte hat uns ja immerhin
energiespeicher in die hosentasche das
auto und ans handgelenk gezaubert
eigentlich sollten wir experten sein was
dieses thema angeht und wenn es um kurze
zeiträume des einsparens geht dann
stimmt das definitiv reden wir aber von
längeren zeiträumen ist das ganze nicht
mehr so einfach herkömmliche akkus wie
zum beispiel lithium ionen können den
übermäßigen strom vom sommer bis zum
winter nicht optimal speichern sie
verlieren stetig an energie durch die
sogenannte selbstentladung es müssen
also technologien für diese art der
langzeitspeicherung gefunden werden aber
wie machen wir das eigentlich jetzt
gerade momentan wird der deutsche markt
von gasspeichern dominiert außerdem
haben wir durch die bisherige nutzung
von kohlekraftwerken eine
kontinuierliche versorgung und sind
dadurch gar nicht so sehr auf speicher
angewiesen global betrachtet werden
jedoch 99 der weltweiten kapazitäten zur
stromspeicherung von
pumpspeicherkraftwerken abgedeckt punkt
speicher werden bereits seit 100 jahren
viel verwendet weil sie viele vorteile
mit sich bringen sie sind eine
etablierte technologie mit hoher
technischer reife haben ein hohes
speichervolumen und gleichzeitig lange
speicherzeiten außerdem haben sie einen
exzellenten wirkungsgrad von circa 80
prozent der wirkungsgrad ist eine zahl
die angibt wie effizient ein system ist
also wie viel der eingegebenen energie
tatsächlich dahin geht wo wir sie haben
wollen und wie viel als verlust zum
beispiel in form von wärme verloren geht
diese wärme könnte in unserem fall zb
bei der pumpe entstehen die heiß wird
und dadurch wärme energie abgibt oder
wasser kann im oberen becken verdunsten
und dann natürlich keinen strom mehr
produzieren
bei einem wirkungsgrad von 100 prozent
würde man theoretisch die gesamte
energie die man gespeichert hat später
wieder zurückbekommen das geht in der
realität leider nicht aber natürlich
strebt man immer einen möglichst hohen
wirkungsgrad an um die verluste gering
zu halten
zum vergleich paar tricks technologien
stehen momentan erst bei einem
wirkungsgrad von ungefähr 40 prozent
ok pumpspeicherkraftwerke sind also die
hidden champions der energiespeicher
aber wie funktioniert so ein
pumpspeicherkraftwerk überhaupt man
nutzt überschüssigen strom um wasser von
einem unteren becken zu einem höher
gelegenen becken zu pumpen so wird
energie in form von potenzielle energie
gespeichert benötigt man dann zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt strom lässt man das
wasser wieder nach unten strömen die
potentielle energie wandelt sich in
bewegungsenergie um und schreibt damit
eine turbine an die mit hilfe eines
generators strom produziert ein
essentielles element von pumpspeichern
ist also ein höhenunterschied aber hier
in deutschland gibt es nicht überall
hohe berge deswegen ist die anzahl von
potentiellen pumpspeicherkraftwerken
limitiert unter anderem deshalb gibt es
in deutschland stand juli 2020 nur 26
punkt speicherkraftwerke das liegt aber
auch daran dass ein höhen
längenverhältnis von eins zu zehn am
optimalsten ist und abweichungen dem
guten wirkungsgrad schaden von dem wir
eigentlich profitieren wollten wie nutzt
man also die vorteile von fünf
wasserspeichern an orten an denen diese
gegebenheiten nicht vorhanden nun
einerseits gibt es die überlegung solche
kraftwerke mit salzwasser auch an küsten
zu bauen wofür aber ebenso eher steile
küstenregionen benötigt werden dies
wiederum auch nicht überall gibt
andererseits wird überlegt in den
nächsten jahren alte stein kohlegruben
oder tagebaue in pumpspeicher
umzuwandeln da dort der höhenunterschied
bereits künstlich geschaffen wurde aber
auch die existieren nicht in hülle und
fülle wir brauchen also neue ideen am
besten genauso zuverlässig langlebig und
effizient nur überall wenn wir die nicht
finden haben wir in zukunft bei der
saisonalen speicherung ein großes
problem also schauen wir mal welche
technologien und demnächst den rücken
freihalten könnten bisherige
pumpspeicherkraftwerke profitieren
allein vom höhenunterschied haben wir
nur einen kleinen berg zur verfügung
also einen kleinen höhenunterschied kann
man das wasser weniger weit nach oben
pumpen und so weniger potenzielle
energie speichern durch eine variation
der technik lassen sich aber weitere
landflächen für pumpspeicher gewinnen
man ersetzt das wasser durch eine
dichtere flüssigkeit dadurch hat man auf
gleiches volumen mehr masse welche man
dann nach oben pumpen kann auf diese
weise kann man mehr energie im oberen
reservoir speichern und bei bedarf auch
wieder nutzen nicht nur der gute
wirkungsgrad ist ein pluspunkt sondern
auch der regionale aspekt am besten ist
es energie dort zu produzieren und zu
speichern wo sie genutzt wird da man so
den verlusten bei der übertragung
entgegenwirkt jedoch lässt sich auch
diese technologie nicht überall in
deutschland einfach so umsetzen also was
gibt es sonst noch so wir können zum
beispiel unsere meere selbst in
energiespeicher umwandeln schließlich
befinden sich über 96 prozent des
wassers in den ozeanen speichert man den
strom von windparks vor ort könnten
diese bei einer flaute die
stromeinspeisung direkt übernehmen das
könnte mit sogenannten unterwasser
pumpspeicherkraftwerken funktionieren
ein geschlossener behälter mit einem
durchmesser von 30 metern wird auf dem
meeresboden in mindestens 700 metern
tiefe installiert wenn überschüssiger
strom vorhanden ist wird dieser dazu
verwendet um wasser aus dem behälter zu
pumpen wenn dann die gespeicherte
energie benötigt wird wird das wasser
wieder in dem hohlraum gelassen durch
den riesigen druck am meeresboden fließt
das wasser dann durch eine turbine und
erzeugt sauberen strom ein vorteil
hierbei ist ein wirkungsgrad von auch
ungefähr 80 außerdem benötigen unter
wasser systeme im vergleich zu
herkömmlichen punkt speichersystemen
kein land in bergen oder tälern das
erste pilotprojekt dass dieses konzept
in die praxis umgesetzt hat war das
projekt sport energy erzielt kurz denn
sie vom fraunhofer institut für
energiewirtschaft und
energiesystemtechnik weitere größer
angelegte projekte sind ebenfalls
geplant bei unserer recherche sind uns
doch andere konzepte untergekommen aber
da waren wir uns nie so wirklich sicher
ob die wirklich serienreif werden können
und ob sie auch kosteneffizient sind
deswegen werden wir die hier erst mal
nicht vorstellen
momentan stecken wir also noch eher in
den kinderschuhen um unser saisonales
speicherproblem zu lösen zum glück
tüftelt die weltweite
forschungsgemeinschaft an lösungen dazu
jedoch wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
diese eine non plus ultra
energiespeicherlösungen geben sondern
wohl eher ein zusammenspiel aus ganz
vielen verschiedenen lösungen besonders
spannend ist auch was mit chemischen
speichern bereits möglich ist die gibt
es auch immer größere innovationen und
höchstwahrscheinlich wird der
suboptimale wirkungsgrad von 40 prozent
hier bald deutlich besser das sind gerne
mal in den kommentaren wissen ob wir
dazu auch ein video machen sollen dann
machen wir das natürlich gerne in diesem
sinne bleibt optimistisch und wie immer
neugieriger cedric